hit him with the dab litzian go
you can do it come on don't be shy it's
still alive it's 20 20. come on bring it
back
let's see you do it just elixir come on
just do it
the things i do for love
[Music]
okay behind the scenes stuff is done
listen high five we're in a concerted
effort and a team bow yeah
he's going to be zoomed in but it's
going to be i've lixie and i'm sorry
i've removed
like 90 of your jokes
[Music]
you can't zoom in what are you gonna do
zoom in on an eyeball
that's not funny that's not funny at all
lichtsy and i'm turning up the game
volume because i think it was a bit
quiet this is a little late to be saying
in episode 8 but
you know i kind of want the volume
generally be nice and audible i don't
want it too quiet too quiet
too bad it's a very fine line don't mess
it up if you mess it up everyone's going
to be mad i'm going to be mad
everyone's going be up don't mess it up
you can't mess it up don't
dare stop oh are you sure oh is that too
quiet
oh is it too loud wait no hang on it
might be too quiet too loud
wait no is that too loud i think i can
hear it too much
oh no now i can't hear it at all okay
that's probably pretty good yeah i think
you're fine maybe
you sure didn't think so
i'm just messing with you am i maybe not
maybe maybe not probably not maybe so
make sure you get it right gold artifact
well it's definitely mysterious what is
it
i don't know but the music's too loud
turn that music down
a couple more notches that's good right
there no wait raise it up
just one one hundredth of a percent
higher if you go above that i swear to
god explain explain to me
that's right i'm a friendly
not you lixian sorry not you have you
ever done that thing where you're
looking out your window and you see
someone walking down the street and you
take your hand and you go to squeeze
their head and pop it like a grape
what if that actually happened this
sounds terrifying
if i didn't know any better i'd say this
is a horror game but i you know honestly
now i can't be sure that it's not
i'm pretty sure it's not but then i did
say a lot of things about popping to
people's heads like
but one thing you got to consider is
that when you're facing down to the vic
and you've only got your flashlight
this one's got some weapon power you
know you can really get some good
like momentum going on this
[Music]
ain't about that no no no i
i don't go in there it just opens
not a joke listen don't worry it's fine
lexi and i cranked up the volume a
little bit hopefully i didn't throw
everything off
if he did i'm sorry lixie and i'm
lexi please you don't need to be so
sassy with me i was just
i was just trying to make it better for
you man please please [ __ ]
please you gotta understand i'm just
trying i'm trying to be a good youtuber
here
please stop where's the this time
[Music]
okay thank you thank you thank you
lindsey who knew that these woods were
haunted by the one and only lixian the
most
dangerous beast of them all
the evilest creature to ever haunt
these woods the
lyxian that's a face that's a face
that's a big face that's a big
big face big face big face litsy and it
looks like your face
why does it look like your face look see
and licks and it looks like your face
look at
your face kind of looks like you're very
kind of does a little bit october 22nd
1999. who's cracking sticks over there
lexie and put it in a jump scare just
keep everyone on their toes but don't
tell them when it's gonna happen keep it
real secret-like
yeah you never know when it's coming now
that i've told lixian to do it you know
it's on the way
[Laughter]
alexia don't do it look sand no
licks in that jump scare
the scum scare the skunk come scare the
jump scare with the skunk
scare him with a skunk
embryo why am i carrying oh there's a
face on it like seeing it kind of looks
like your face
no not at all your face isn't drippy and
weird oh
okay
okay that's a nice identification
drawing right there
lexi zoom in on that oh man hey it's you
you put some spiky hair on that it looks
just like you
no your art's better no that's not what
i'm saying i'm i'm not saying you're
no it's just i mean you're
you can see the resemblance take your
hair off
take it off
see i'm sorry
i'm sorry this does remind me of um uh
shrubbity upset what's the name elixion
what's the name of the game the the the
sewer game with the beep the game that i
beat the one that i definitely
beat ooh what was the name of that
nemesis
was it nemesis no that doesn't sound
right now this is so
my editor is portuguese
he will have no idea how to translate
anything so
lixian good luck but what i did ordered
is a
sampling of different sandwiches and
different burgors
or as they call it in korea hamburgl
lexing do you know how to translate that
good
now olenno's orlos
this portuguese legend
can you read this looks in
well look seen you must know a way out
of here
you've got to know these are your people
you've probably been on this train right
you know
you know aperte zee for
we are to turn on and off the lantern
this is portuguese
legs ahead how about okay
[Music]
it is portuguese lexian this is the
language of your people
i couldn't talk at all ah weird huh it
was like i was
suffocating this is amazing don't touch
that icon
anymore i love your accent
is it portuguese is that a portuguese
accent
lexia
did you make this i guess that's me
assuming that you're the only person in
portugal which is not true
did you make it time sure flies when
you're having fun right lindsey
ah you uh with all your jokes
god you're a silly silly silly
silly portuguese man you know even if it
was like my best friend
i don't know if i could say i'd go into
a place like this
looking for them
hi how are you oh hi
what are you doing there are you a
monster
i am the thing in the wall i feel
nothing but pain
the cruelty of my existence is something
that is only tamed by the suffering of
others
great good don't do anything scary now
oh you anyway
anyway i feel like this isn't very
important but it might be important you
never know what's going to be important
you never know what's not going to be
important i don't know how good i'm
going to do in this
i'm going to text lisa and just tell me
actually i'm not even going to ask him
what it's what it's for give me a random
word
any man now legs again he's not getting
back to me
oh no okay i'm asking wade hey can you
give me a random word
any word
where is everybody somebody give me a
word
gosh important that you need to pick a
one perfect
lixian got back to me pop
pop sickle all right thank you alexia
thank you thank you thank you popsicle
spelled exactly that way it's not how
i would spell popsicle but maybe the
portuguese spell it slightly differently
oh no how do i get in nobody's home
lexi and listen i need you to make me
look good
really good no don't talk no lixie don't
listen to him
don't listen to either of them just make
me look pretty focus slicks in
put a beauty filter over my face
more beauty beautifuler there we go
dude my improv is off the charts right
now no your hip-hop's great but my my
monetization is just tanking
every word okay censor out ass and
replace it with jesus
yeah if if also lixian could you do that
as well
i want to put my friendship in your
jesus that's it that's the one
tell me thank jesus i want to put my
jesus
inside your [ __ ] no no no no sorry
lexi
you messed up there think about it again
okay re-edit all right
jesus jesus inside your
[ __ ] jesus [ __ ] jesus
jesus jesus jesus jesus let me try i'm
gonna try to do something
try to go to markiplier.spreadtruth.com
editor
lixian hey how you doing you're
beautiful man
but i put it right did you put it did
you put did you do a good job but i put
it in his wraith
editor editor put it show that i had it
editor please show
how that was true
everyone knows it everyone agrees
no one is disputing this fact and facts
are what are important when it comes
down to
the world we live in oh don't run into
the cactus yeah [ __ ]
all right let's keep the potty language
to a minimum okay
uh [ __ ] hole oh my god
you're gonna make extra work for elixion
to censor all of that
oh my god don't you know i'm a
family-friendly channel now
people couldn't even see the game on
that one lixian what you're gonna have
to do
you're gonna you're gonna go snatch the
vod from
their stream put my face cam over their
face cam
and that's what we're gonna deal with
okay cool
[Music]
uh
god these crickets are just so great
yeah that chirping noise is like gonna
destroy my ears
alexian can you cut out that frequency
from the audio that's
can you can you apply several layers of
d-hum to this and ruin the audio
completely oh no listen that
that buzzing is at a very specific
frequency if you cut out that frequency
that buzzing goes away but that's the
same as my voice
oh this is so much to read the lore
let's see and summarize it for me and
then somehow get it to me
uh in reverse time so that i know it now
and i don't have to know it later
oh it's an infusion of knowledge in my
face
all the effects are so glowy
okay anyway now i know alexander sound
the alarms
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you i am not holding that against
you alexian the
animated a paper plane going in and
hitting off of bessie's nose there
ah yeah that was real good that was
worth the effort to put into making that
happen i'm glad i
asked that plain jane plain can't play
how plane do plane do lexi and throw a
plane across the screen
what is this game called lexi and put it
on screen quick
flick scene hit the mission successful
music
that's the good stuff right there that's
good let's see and make this
good can you make it good
all right lexie and just time-lapse this
because i'm about to go
i'm about to go deep and i mean that
both literally
and figuratively i'm about
i have like no wood oh god i'm such a
tit oh god how do i
don't you better have started that time
lapse you i've seen you better
started the time lapse i do not need
people seeing this i do not need people
seeing me fail to make a pickaxe
i don't need it none of us need it so
just
get on his shears i'll need ladders
maybe
lexie in the timelapse it started right
please to god please
please all right i don't think i need
the x but i'll take it anyway just
all right okay time lapse go
lexie and keep the time lapse going but
make it really cool make it like the
coolest make it the sweetest time lapse
anyone's ever seen
make it so unbelievably cool that
everyone's gonna watch this video and
they're gonna be like whoa
that time lapse that time lapse was sick
that was like the best time lapse i've
ever seen in my life
that was just a nuts time lapse from
start to finish
so um like i don't know more than just
like cool music and whatnot
make it like uh something that people
will really remember forever and i'm
done
okay that time lapse better have been
good
was it good
thank you
eyes on the prize maybe eyes on the
prize
ding ding ding ding ding ding dixie and
sound the alarm sound the music
cue the quiring angels the sweetest
taste that ever was toasted
the sweetest taste the sweetest
delete everything delete everything
click scene please i'm begging you you
have to delete
licks in please you don't understand
like said
you have to delete everything i am
no one could know i'm going to put money
into this
and i'm going to count on you not to let
anybody know about this
don't put this at the end of the video
after i've already said goodbye
just don't tell anybody about this it's
just between you
oh hey uh how did i miss the oh found
the door key okay i missed the key it
was staring at me in the face
lexian uh cut around that make me look
really good
uh don't make me look like a big dump
dummy remember i got the big brain
so i can't possibly be the big dumb at
the same time
physiologically impossible me and big
brain all time but me i'm small brain no
time make that
make that make sense okay
no oh i'm getting it now i'm getting it
now
everything is coming together like a cow
lexington cut all this out of it yeah i
never want anyone to ever hear about
anything that i'm trying
okay that's not staying there well
that's not really that much fair
i want to try something else quick but i
can't so i'll grab my dick
lacie please cut out all of this i don't
want anyone to see any of this i wanted
no one to know
anything that happened here you know to
each their own
lexi and cut that out for the love of
god do not show anybody that looks eaten
please
look seeing looks in
looks gonna cut that out make it sound
like a real cry
no alexander i'm going to cut this out
so no one sees it of course
but uh i'm going to just like heave and
you
add crying in make it sound really
realistic like like create like this
sound
synthesizer of my voice using all the
voice that i've
had in my videos shouldn't take too long
here we go
how many of you knew that was going to
happen and you did nothing to
stop me from doing said action lixian
did you know did you know that would
happen
because i didn't how could you
how could you if i'm not actually crying
animate like some tears in or if that's
too hard just
slap me in the face i don't care if you
want to see more scary games they are
as always linked in the description
lixium show
lixium i'm sorry i'm sorry
i i didn't mean to say your name wrong i
just
i i've you know so it's late in the
night i i've been recording a while i've
been saying a lot of words i didn't mean
no
no please no go back no
lyxiam i mean links in uh
lixian put on like some hopeful music
you know it's
kind of like new beginnings i am
recording right
my mic is on correct yeah put on
something like hopeful like new
beginnings like
mistakes something that evokes the
feeling that mistakes have been made in
the past but they
they won't bog me down i won't be
stopped just because of the
inconveniences of the world around me or
the the sins of my own
past something something really really
like
heartwarming fulfilling soul bonding
yeah something like that
[Applause]
something like that i hope lixian's
keeping the music nice and high so that
we can
hear it all in all it's glory but not
too high elixion
you don't want to ruin people's
listening experience now do you
oh maybe that might be too quiet oh you
never know with these things
better get it right lixie and play the
epic journey music that i told you about
in the episode that didn't get recorded
you know the one when i told you to play
the epic journeying music
that was gonna take me across the
mountaintops so that i could reach a new
land and be
safe you remember the one right play the
exact one that we were talking about
before when i was talking to you and i
didn't get the episode to you
you remember it right right good thank
you
play it now
that's not the song
play the song you remember the one
so play it
wrong one you get it wrong again
and i'll cut your hair off permanently
is that the right one
so you don't want to be wrong
are you sure
go with it if you're confident
oh hey that's the right one oh thank you
oh cool alexia and put on like some
cliche
dating sim music going on here real
plunky
real uh you know you know the type you
love yourself a uh
dating suit came to you i know
you i know you come on you
you love them you you love them
too much but i don't judge it's okay all
right you go enjoy put in the music all
right cool
thank you of whom i've got
no one of good lauren and
[Laughter]
what i don't know what i just read oh my
oh my god
oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
lexi and i'm not crazy right this is
cool right okay cool
high five all right cool we're on the
same page
he makes games he makes games he makes a
game he made me a game did you see that
he made me a game little game
for my birthday it's not special hey a
game
oh this is no time for games i like game
hey this looks like lixian's game i am
the best
i want to thank my mom i want to thank
lixian
listen lixie and i i'm gonna have to
leave you behind now my career is taking
off right now
i am obviously the best and i listen i
don't want to hold
you back that's what it i want you to be
able
i'm finding success now now you need to
find
success so you roll on out of here yeah
all right see oh that's cute
okay bye okay
i should do yeah i i i don't know i know
i'm putting it in your hands but i trust
your capable spooking skills
you're so amazing you're such a good
editor
you're so goddamn talented as an
animator
and as a person one
okay and then scare him to death let's
see and scare him to death
it's okay i'll get back up there in two
seconds two shakes of a lamb's tail
two shake it two shake shake this shake
it baby
shake it lick see and shake it shake it
come on
come on please this weird no it's not
it's
weird not weird it's okay it's cool
it's glixing cut all this out i don't
want any of this ever i literally
am stopping by because lixian is
playing resident evil right now and
uh i just wanted to stop by give him a
super sticker so i just took a little
break to
priest lixie and everyone preach lixian
lixie and point them in the right
direction
so right down there in the description
thank you thank you lixian thank you so
much for helping out
you're such a oh you're just so you're
so nice
ah man i don't want to make you do lots
of work you're such
you're so great everyone should
subscribe to you
[Music]
so that was three scary games thank you
all so much for watching hope you
hi lunky
hey luxian how are you doing
let's see and end the end video for me
please end it for me i i don't have
i don't have the willpower anymore i
don't have the willpower
okay i don't have the willpower
i don't know
[Music]
ah cool good good job lixon you did it
i'm proud of you unless you didn't
did you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
oh i'm not done recording hey hi lexian
how you doing